welcome to this meeting of baba district
castle cabinet
i'm councillor john ward leader of david
district council
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and we will be capable of repeated
viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public
and the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i'll now ask the government's officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members we also have councillor
mccror
joining us today and chief executive
arthur civonia
strategic director kathy nixon and
monitoring officer emily yule
thank you thank you
can i now move to the agenda please so
firstly we've got item one
apologies for absence thank you chair we
have no apologies
thank you item two to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
nope item three
paper bca 2010 confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting of the baby
cabinet
held on the 9th of november 2020 and
you'll find these
on pages 7 to 12 of your report
so um what i'll do is i'll just go
through these
page by page to page 7
page eight page nine
page ten page
eleven uh and that's it actually there's
a page twelve
so does anyone have any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
if not may i have a proposal please
i'll propose thank you castle rbc
thank you may i have a second to please
mr chairman councillor general's born
thank you councillor right
that's um that's that
uh so maybe have the electronic vote for
the minutes please
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the
moderngod.gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right of the agenda
and selecting attendance and voting the
voting tab the vote for this agenda item
will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote
just waiting for one vote uh
thank you councillors that's unanimous
chair eight votes for
thank you claire right uh next item item
four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
nominee chair item five questions by
councillors
non-received chair and item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees
there were none too thank you
item seven uh forthcoming decisions list
um
have if you've all had a chance i hope
to look at the latest version of the
forthcoming decisions list
does anyone have any comments on it
nope okay then
um i think we can uh continue on to the
the next item
item eight which is paper bca2011 the
general fund financial monitoring
2020 to 2021 quarter two
i'm pleased to present report bca 2020
uh
pca 2011 to cabinet the general fund
course to do financial monitoring for
for this year covering the revenue and
capital financial performance for the
period april to september 2020
this is our second look at how we think
our general fund is shaping up for the
full year compared with the budget
and it incorporates the up-to-date
impact of covered 19 on the council's
finances
we continue to monitor and update the
impact of the unplanned costs and loss
of income due to covert 19
and the government financial support we
have and are receiving
the government has recently announced
that there will yet again be a one-year
comprehensive spending review settlement
we're still awaiting a review of
business rates and the next revaluation
will now take place on first of april
2023
based on april 2021 property values
to ensure that the effects of covert are
taken into account
looking at the impact of covert 19 the
financial impact of coin 19
the additional costs income reduction
impact on council tax and business rates
offset by the financial support we have
received to date is presented in section
5 of the report
we have additional unplanned costs of
just under 1 million pounds and a
reduction in income from our sales fees
and charges of about 1.2 million pounds
the collection fund deficit is expected
to be around 200 000 pounds
before i go on please note that some of
the numbers in paragraphs 1.2 and 5.11
are incorrect but the tables at
paragraphs 5.8
and 6.8 are correct
the table in paragraph 5.8 lists all the
perfect government funding we have
received
a date and this is currently a total of
1.869 million pounds
the table in paragraph 6.8 includes
1.822 million pounds of this
with the remaining 47 000 pounds having
been transferred to the hra
as explained in melissa's monthly
covered financial updates
as described in paragraph 5.9 we now
know that the government will cover 75
of irrecoverable sales fees and charges
losses above 5
of planned income also the collection
fund deficit can be spread over the next
three years
the government has provided us with a
lot of support and as a result of this
together with our usual careful
management we have been able to protect
the council's finances from what could
have been a
devastating situation however there
remains a significant risk
that this could change as the year
progresses there is still so much
uncertainty about the further impact of
covert
although the progress with vaccine
development and rollout gives us all
hope for optimism
in the meantime we're still having to
cope with that uncertainty
particularly around the collection fund
and ongoing support for our leisure
centers
we don't yet know when or how they will
open or whether abby croft will be
successful in bidding into the 100
million pounds set aside for
compensating third-party providers
finally recruitment has now commenced
and so the vacancy management factor
saving is unlikely to continue at such a
high level
i'm pleased to report that the revenue
account position for the council remains
positive
and has improved since quarter one
whilst the total financial impact of
code 19 is
currently 2.331 million pounds as
mentioned earlier
we have anticipated a total of 1.822
million
in financial support by the year end
including an estimate for irrecoverable
sales fields
fees and charges income which is 78 of
our costs and losses
leaving a predicted covered impact of
510 000 pounds
after taking into account positive
variances as listed
in the table at paragraph 6.8 we are
anticipating a surplus of 728 000 pounds
for the year
whilst this is good news we shouldn't
get carried away by it as it will
undoubtedly change over the remaining
months
the key variances compared with budget
are set out in paragraph 6.6
some no notable items other than the
covered losses
as follows we're now forecasting a
positive variance of 164
000 pounds for cifco compared with an
adverse variance of a hundred and three
thousand pounds of quarter one
we are forecasting an adverse variance
of seventy thousand pounds due to loss
of income from our other commercial
properties
and this is an improvement over the 175
000 pounds fork um
loss uh adverse variants forecasts at
quarter one
loss of car park income expect is
expected to result in an adverse
variance of a hundred and ten thousand
pounds
and there is an adverse variance of two
hundred and forty eight thousand pounds
due to a reduction in income from the
waste services
both of these are slightly worse than
quarter one
there is an adverse variance of 228 000
pounds
for planning comprised of a loss of
income of 278
000 pounds offset by a savings of 53
thousand pounds for other items
this is a very small improvement on the
quarter one position
we are predicting a reduction of eighty
two thousand pounds in income from our
other investments
there is an expected four hundred and
fifty thousand pound favorable variance
for our five percent
vacancy management factor which is a
reduction from the 592 000 pounds
reported a quarter one as recruitment is
slowly picks up
an adverse variance of 356 000 pounds is
expected for business rates
which is an improvement on 389 000
pounds a quarter one
although there is a marked increase in
the adverse variance of baseline
business rates which is offset partly by
an increase in the section 31 grants
that we will receive but mostly by an
improved situation with the business
rates pool since quarter one
the impact on the collection fund is now
estimated at 206 000 pounds
in addition to the government funding we
are also including 456 000 pounds of
other funding and support
that is housing benefit income to cover
homelessness costs
track and trace funding community grant
under spend and the
shared revenue partnership absorbing
some additional costs
we received 870 000 pounds of still
income in the first six months of this
year which is down from one million
pound for the same period last year
apart from the five percent admin charge
this will be transferred to the
earmarked reserve
paragraph 6.11 of the report summarizes
the current
predicted movements in the
transformation fund
the forecast balance of 875 000 pounds
at the end of the year
at this stage we're not showing a
transfer of any of the budget surplus
to this as it is likely along with other
reserve movements to change the
transformation fund details are provided
in appendix b
appendix a shows how we are spending 100
business rates retention pilot funding
748 000 pounds is still unspent of which
280 000 pounds
as yet unallocated appendix c
sets out our general fund year marked
reserves including forecast transfers
these have increased slightly since
quarter one and now just under 5.4
million pounds excluding still
looking at the medium term we know that
new homes bonus is being phased out
for 2020 to 21 it will be 1.05 million
pounds but it is forecast to be only 205
000 pounds by 2022 to 23. the median
term position presented in paragraphs
5.14 to 5.16 remains as before
an increasing deficit from 1.1 million
pounds to 2.3 million pounds
over the three years to 2023 to 24
with 1.4 million pounds impacting in the
next year
the comprehensive budget challenge
commenced in august 2020
is now well advanced now in the cabinet
together with officers
are identifying significant savings as
well as reviewing all
and i stress all of our fees and charges
use of reserves will be a last resort as
it doesn't represent a sustainable
strategy
as we now know the impact of curve at 19
is likely to be felt for many years to
come
finally our general fund capital program
is detailed in appendix d
and paragraph 615 to 617.
curved 19 has resulted in a number of
delays and increased costs
excluding cifco we have a 20.1 million
pound revised capital expenses program
this year
with an anticipated spend of 3.5 million
pounds
we are now carrying forward 12.7 million
pounds leaving it under spend this year
just under 4 million pounds
mostly due to the cancellation of the
bellevue hotel project
the main variances relating to the
carried forwards and underspends are
listed in paragraph 617
and appendix d i would like to thank our
finance team for all their hard work
not just tracking the progress against
budget in a rapidly changing situation
but they have also had to prepare the
regular covered returns to government
and for the past couple of months or so
they've been working on next year's
budget
so thanks to all of them before opening
up for questions and debate
i'd first like to move the
recommendation in section 3 of the
report
that the castle's financial position at
the end of quarter 2 be noted
may i have a second of this
recommendation please
i'm happy to second that john yeah
thanks thanks castle davis
right okay so
um firstly questions from cabinet
members
counselor arthi do you have any
questions
um no thank you chairman councillor
busby
do you have any questions um thanks
tonight's point
council davis do you have questions
no thank you no councillor holt
do you have any questions
and um councillor malviti do you have
any questions
not at this point thank you thank you
councillor osborne
do you have any questions thank you mr
chairman no not at this point i do not
thank you
okay and finally councillor parker do
you have any
questions uh well
actually i do uh chair if i might okay
just just one
if if that's okay i'm looking at uh page
30 appendix
c uh with regards to the general fund
earmarked reserves
um i'm just uh inquiring
about the commuted maintenance reserve
there's quite a large transfer there
376k
could you could you give me some um some
info on that
uh yes there's actually significant
uh thanks for asking that um luckily
i've done my research um
uh there's a significant increase in
quarter one um which is an additional um
294
000 i believe from quarter one and
that's um
uh commute uh one-off commuted sums
payment from persimmon homes
for some bartholomew's development in
sudbury
okay
right okay so um are there any other
questions
from any other members present um if so
would you please
show hands
okay well then we will move
into debate um if there are no other
questions from anyone
any other cabinet members want to come
up with a quick question
on the um the report itself if not
we will go in straight into the debate
um counselor arthi
uh first off for you do you have
anything you wish to say about the
budget
um no no thank you chairman um i mean
basically we're
um looking at uh um how can i put this a
statement of fact if you like
and no i i support the recommendation
thank you
okay castle busby
well i think it's a statement of fact at
this point
the fact is that the facts will change
over the next few months so
but it's looking good it's uh a lot
better than it was
um and i'm pleased to see that but no
other point thanks
yeah you're right it's a lot better and
and as i
stress in my report that's that's a
combination of two things that um
the government has been good um but um
our team has has been even better in um
uh coping with uh the um
the increased costs and uh the reduction
in income
uh councillor councillor davis yeah i
just want to um
reaffirm that point i i think the team
have done amazing that
when we um we last looked at the budget
it wasn't looking particularly good i
mean it's still not
100 great and we don't know what's going
forward but the work that's been done to
to put us on an even keel um yeah with
the support of the government i guess
to an extent but more so because of the
the way we we've had to work and the
officers done an excellent job
to make sure um things are good but
going forward we still need to do an
awful lot more
in terms of a making money and and
trying to find a way forward in terms of
the budget
so good good overall but i think we've
still got some troubled waters ahead
yeah thank you council hall
yeah i'd like to concur that really i
think it's it's obviously been a very
difficult year
and it's nice to see an improving
picture being being put
in front of us today and we have got
some more months to go
so it may well improve a bit more but we
were facing some very difficult
decisions and we still do face some
difficult decisions but with this
improvement picture
i think overall it's very encouraging
yeah thank you councilman of easy
i agree with my fellow counselors to
date
um considering when we last looked at it
it was
not a pretty picture it is somewhat
improved and dare i
say i'm quietly cautiously
optimistic thank you very much chair
thank you that's laura osborne yeah
thank you mr chairman yeah it's a good
report and well set up and as has been
alluded to by several other
members of the cabinet um a big thank
you to the officers for putting the
report together
and indeed for putting the budget
together
we are where we are and um it is we have
got
a few more months to go and i know that
these are going to be challenging months
but i just hope that the budget improves
by the time we come to improving
it at full council for the um 2122
budget
we obviously have some challenges and we
have some really difficult decisions to
make and i can't
underestimate that it's not easy for
councillors to make those decisions but
make them we will have to um but no it's
looking good and
again many thanks to the officers for
their hard work
thank you mr chairman thank you and
finally councillor parker
thank you chair and i just concur with
everything that my colleagues have said
i mean hopefully there'll be a few
less sleepless nights in there finally
compared to what we were we were looking
at earlier in the year so
um under the circumstances very well
done but of course as
as all of my cabinet colleagues have
said it's it's it's a very guarded
um and and cautious uh welcome to um to
this report
thank you thank you right
um if there are no further comments uh
i'll ask
uh council macro
you did have an opportunity in the
questions well there wasn't a question
oh okay all right i didn't think it was
appropriate
all i was going to say was that from a
scrutiny and i might add an audit point
of view
that uh the evidence base that would be
presented
it seems very clear reports well
constructed and uh
the conclusions that the cabinet seem to
be coming to i think would be supported
or certainly there's enough evidence to
support them in a scrutiny or an audit
meeting and that's all they will
obviously eventually
filter through to us when we consider
the final budget
thank you very much and and again i just
concur to the idea
officers have done an amazing job and
we've seen that in both audit and in
scrutiny
thank you councillor thank you right
well i'll now ask the governor's office
to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors if you go
back into your
modern gov app and select the plus sign
at the top
the vote for this item is now in blue
just oh
thank you that's eight votes four chair
that's unanimous
thank claire thank you right now moving
on to item nine which is paper bca 2012
the housing revenue account for natural
monitoring for 2020 to 2021
quarter two
i'm pleased now to introduce report bca
2012
to cabinet the housing revenue account
called to do financial monitoring for
this year
the report covers the hra revenue budget
and the hra capital program for the
period april to september 2020.
this is our second look at how we think
our hra is looking for the full year
compared with budget
and as with the general fund it
incorporates the up-to-date impact of
code 19 on the council's finances
code 19 is having a financial impact on
the council's hra
rent levels are at a risk repairs and
maintenance was reduced to emergency
repairs for existing tenants only
and there was the need to complete void
work in order to support the
accommodation of the homeless and rough
sleepers
the new build program also had to stop
during lockdown
new building repairs and maintenance
have now restarted but they now carry
additional costs
in order to proceed safely service
levels will take time to recover and
there will be a backlog of work
as the year progresses this financial
impact will be forecast with more
certainty
but the current impact assessment is
presented in section 5 of the report
the additional costs due to curvature
mainly the need for ppe
amounted forty seven thousand pounds and
which has been transferred from the
government supports grants money
so far we have seen a minimal impact on
rent levels but a rental loss provision
of 882
000 pounds has been included as in
quarter one
rents are expected to be reclaimed
eventually rather than written off but
this will extend beyond the current
financial year
as there is currently no hra support in
government we will cover this from our
very healthy strategic priorities
reserve
the revenue position is detailed in
paragraph 6.3 to 6.11
and as always the financial position of
the hrh should be viewed in the context
of the updated
30-year business plan the budget set in
february showed a forecast surplus
position for 2020 to 21 of 334 000
pounds
at quarter one we were forecasting a
deficit of 17 000 pounds
but the position now is a forecast
surplus of one point seven million
pounds
which represents a favorable variance of
one point three six six million against
budget
the table in paragraph 6.3 lists the
main items
in the budget and a detailed breakdown
of the variances
is provided in paragraph 6.6 to 6.10
there is a forecast income shortfall of
790 000 pounds
comprised of as i said earlier adverse
variance in income from dwelling rents
and this is based on a 15 reduction for
26 weeks
and is after taking into account those
tenants receiving housing benefit or
universal credit
this is offset by small favorable
variances for service charges and
non-dwelling rents
and a one-off receipt of an easement
relating to land and property
land in sudbury offsetting this our
expenditure underspends elsewhere within
the hra
there's a favorable variance of 114
thousand pounds for housing management
which is slightly down on the quarter
one figure
175 000 pounds a favorable variance of
214 thousand pounds for a response
responsive repairs and maintenance which
is an increase on the quarter one figure
of 146 000 pounds
there's a favorable favorable variance
of 159 000 pounds for planned
maintenance
which is a decrease on the quarter one
figure of 182 000 pounds
there is a favorable variance of 1.669
million pounds for the revenue
contribution to capital
and this is forecast because because of
slippage
in the 20 20 to 21 capital program
it is this that has been the primary
contributor to the overall surplus this
time
as it hadn't yet included in the quarter
one numbers
all this means that our hra balances are
forecast to be 15.655 million pounds as
detailed in paragraph 611.
covert has had a huge impact on our
capital program this year
and the normally difficult task of
accurately assessing the level of
payments for complex
capital schemes has become almost
impossible the capital program has
itemized an appendix a
and further detail provided in paragraph
612 to 615 of the report
actual capital expenditure april to
september totals 2.4 million pounds
against a budget of 28.8 million pounds
although they have restarted projects
have fallen behind schedule
and their budgets will be carried
forward to meet expenditure incurred
next year
we are expecting the full year capital
spend to be
18.279 million pounds with 10.161
million pounds being carried forward
and again before opening up for
questions and debate i'd first like to
move the recommendation in section 3 of
the report
that the council's financial position at
the end of quarter to be noted
may i have a second for this
recommendation please
i'd like to say thank you please yes
thank you
yeah thank you okay then um so
again i'll run through um questions from
cabinet members
council arthi do you have any questions
um i have got one small one
um paragraph 6.8 um
the responsive repairs and maintenance
and it's
i think the last bullet point on that
page which is um the offset
of 33 000 pounds for covering vacant
posts
um i just wondered if we could have a
bit more detail on that
six point eight
six point eight and it's the last
bullet point it's the offset of 33 000
pounds for covering vacant posts
right okay um
i don't personally have the answer to
that
um melissa do you have an answer for
that one
or catherine hi thank you
um no i don't have the details to hand
but i'm happy to go away and
get that and give you a written answer
for that one if that's okay
thank you yes so it's it's relating to
agency and consultancy costs
yeah i'll get the details on that and
share that with the cabinet okay
yeah thank you thanks
okay um do you have any other questions
councillorathe
no thank you chairman counselor
thanks jer 4.4 we talk about
the council's housing stock at 3418
homes
no doubt we've bought some and so and
we've sold some could you
somebody tell me whether that's going up
or going down
well um i don't have the precise numbers
to hand here but based on
um evidence recently of right to buy
sales versus our bills and acquisitions
the number is definitely most definitely
going up
um as an example 2019 to 2020 our right
to buy sales were
11 and we acquired a significantly more
than that
uh council osman do you have the actual
numbers
i don't have the actual numbers because
obviously um the last i got is september
and it's changed even since
september because they change on a
monthly basis there are a lot of sites
coming forward so even if the
figure hasn't increased since quarter to
quarter
one by the time we get into quarter
three and quarter to four quarters four
there will be a significant increase
um i think it's important to remember as
well that we will be approving once the
budget's been approved next year
we'll be improving the new hra business
case
which will set out where we propose to
go with our development program
but i haven't actually got the figures
to date but if mr councillor busby
wishes i can provide that to him i've
got plenty of emails tucked away
somewhere that i can forward
to him with the exact figures actually
um
i just found some numbers um which
were accurate as as in the summer um for
2020
this current year well for last year
2019 to 2020 well i said that uh we
sold 11th right to buy we built 10 and
it bought 18.
um so that's a net gain of 17.
for 20 20 to 21 as current year
as of the july we bought 45
um there were 3300 contract 63 under
offer which included the waldenfield
road
and we commenced uh construction
obviously an angel caught in hadley
which is 21
a sighting shopping for eight and a
sight in brampton for nine
so uh you can see that there's been
significant activity despite covered
and and uh the restrictions that's
imposed this year
okay thanks it's good to see that the
figure's going up and i congratulate you
on your dexterity in finding those
numbers
thank you council davis
no no congratulations uh and no
questions
okay thanks counselor
yeah just a couple of things on the
building services the responsive repairs
are we now back up and
repairing those as they come in or are
we still prioritizing those it's just
i have had recently a few contacts with
residents who have been waiting some
considerable time for what may be
classed as non-urgent
but obviously to them they are still
important repairs and secondly
on the building services one where we've
got a favorable variance of 159k the
plan maintenance
do we anticipate being able in the next
12 months to
get ahead of the plan maintenance
schedule in that we'll be able to
carry out what has been now backlogged
maintenance and get on top of it
gavin are you able to answer any of
those
yes thank you thank you chair and uh
good afternoon
cabinet um if i could just come back to
an earlier question
in relation to the costs of building
services
members will be familiar that we have
had
an interim manager um in the service
since december last year
uh chris peck leaves us next week
following the successful appointment of
keith turner to corporate manager so
you will understand that as a result of
having in the interim
manager there were additional costs
incurred
we've also had some additional staff um
from agencies covering long-term
sickness
and obviously trying to invest in the
service and
make the inroads that i and i know
members want to see
in terms of the both the quality and the
delivery of those services
we've had some agency staff supporting
us at certain times but
i would expect that to to resolve itself
in the forthcoming
weeks and months just in relation
to uh the points raised by councillor
halt
yes we are back as much as we can be to
uh business as usual uh i think it's
really positive that baby mid-suffolk
district councils were
able to maintain uh a level of uh
repairs
uh throughout the initial lockdown and
then subsequently
we are adhering to government guidance
and that requires us to have
safe systems of work in place naturally
as a result of some of those things you
can expect that
performance might dip in terms of for
example using ppe
uh and the amount of jobs that can be
done per day but um we are
at the moment still providing some form
of triage
um through the team to ensure that our
resources are prioritized uh to those in
greatest need and obviously to
to the repairs i'm happy outside of the
meeting uh to receive any feedback about
specifics because obviously there may be
a narrative around those
um obviously we've had um
some level of displacement as a result
of materials
uh but actually within the service we
are doing everything we can
to uh limit the impact of
shortages of material supply both as a
result of covert
and any challenges that we face in the
forth coming weeks so we are trying to
mitigate
uh wherever possible thank you gavin
thanks
sorry john yeah yeah gavin the
the plan maintenance will you be able to
get back on track within the next 12
months or is that going to be a delay
that's going to be
carried forward i am so sorry that i am
failed to answer that question um
totally forgot um so
in terms of the planned maintenance
schedule um yes i would expect
us to uh play a level of catch up uh so
for example
if it was a particular contract for a
certain type of works
the next contract that we let we will
let uh with more
or more multiple properties in that
contract but i think what is really
positive and there was
uh local media coverage this week for
example the the nearly million pounds
that we are investing in minding and
cavendish way
uh through planned maintenance
improvements um
that that will make uh that whole area
uh much
better for those tenants and
leaseholders that live there so
um we've also got external wall
insulation programs going on in
springlands at the moment
um and parts of cornard uh again
uh looking at improvements that we can
make so um
yes we'll inevitably try and catch up uh
wherever possible
some of the work that we are doing um in
response to
um the budget challenge and developing
the budget for next year
is for example looking at our spend so
where we've relied on
contractors to provide certain works for
example
uh fencing uh our intentions are to
uh reduce contract to spend and employ
uh our own
uh um operatives to carry out certain
work so for example in fencing
uh we will have a gang of offenses um
improving uh hopefully the uh the
quality and
the uh delivery of those types of
repairs
but more so we're also looking at
apprenticeships um and additional
carpenters and plumbers as well
thank you very very sure in that thank
you
thanks kevin um councillor malvisi
you're next i've got nothing to add or
to ask
thank you thank you council osborne as
cabinet member for housing
have you got any questions no i'm more
than happy with the report i certainly
haven't got any questions
i will have something to say during the
debate if that's okay thank you yeah i
thought you would yeah
okay councillor parker
uh no chair no no further questions
thank you
right are there any other questions from
from any other members present
in that case um we'll move open
uh over to the debate and i'll now open
the item up for debate
so casarathi do you wish to say anything
in the debate
well it's it's a follow-up to the
questions really um and it's about our
council housing stock um and what's
happening to
um the the totals because as far as i
can make out and i've just looked it up
in november 2016
our stock was 3505
and it now appears to be what was it
um 3416 or something so
we're actually not back up to 2006
levels yet
are we to 2006 levels no well there has
been uh
2000 2006 there have been
16 2016
right okay um i'll have to
get back to you on that because i don't
have numbers um in front of me going
back
that far to be honest
so um gavin can you comment on that
i'll just let you know i got it from the
business plan um which was published in
2017.
uh i apologize i can't give you an
answer i'm happy to go away
um and look at the numbers when we
uh produce stock reports we inevitably
will produce them with
uh different types of stock for example
social rent affordable rent sheltered
but i'll go away and look at the totals
what i can do is reassure members
without providing you with the actual
numbers that obviously
since 2012 and um self-financing and the
ability for baber
uh district council to start to invest
in developing its own
housing stock that we have seen
ultimately a net improvement in the
overall numbers
that inevitably has coincided with
what was significant numbers of right to
buys
uh up till the crash in 2200
2008 then a an increase
in the intervening years but since um
2014 actually a further decline in
right to buy so inevitably uh the more
properties we can build and the less
right to buy as we have
um it will improve the overall bottom
line but i'll go away
and provide all members with some
numbers
uh going back over the last 10 years
thanks kevin thank you um
councillor buzzfeed do you have anything
you wish to say at this stage
well just disappointed in your dexterity
not going back to 2016. 2016
please try and do better okay
we'll do castle davis
no no i'm all good thank you
councillor holt no all good thank you
councilman rbc no nothing thank you
councillor i was born yeah thank you mr
chairman first of all i
if i could just uh go back to what on
councillor arthi was saying
i found that really strange so i should
be going looking back at all these
figures to check that out because
we in 2016 we set a target to develop
214
new properties to add to our housing
stock
and um as at september we were halfway
there
so i find that figure really strange so
i'll be interested to get the
up-to-date data from officers to see
where that is um
the actual report itself is looking
really good and again i
i think to gavin and his team the
housing team
and to the finance team really well done
for putting this report together and
it is looking good however again we
cannot
underestimate the challenges that we've
got in the next few months and way way
beyond that as
far as the housing team are concerned so
it's well done to everybody what i would
say
um mr chairman is please could we
show in the hra budget a ring fenced
amount
for mobile cctv cameras
um hopefully we're going to approve
today at cabinet
cct funding for sudbury and hadley
for new new cameras which is great
but it won't account for the use of
mobile cameras throughout
our district and as we know the social
housing white paper was recently
published and there's an
it's got seven key promises and one of
those is
emphasis on uh restricting and reducing
anti-social behavior
and by having mobile cameras it was
proven to work really well in minden
cavendish in sudbury recently
and i would very much hope that we could
uh reinfest some amount in the hra
so that we can provide uh mobile cameras
in the future
um where we've got particular
anti-social hot spots
coming forward especially on our on our
own developments
but otherwise excellent report thank you
to both teams for that housing team and
the finance team
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor parker
uh thank you chair no no further comment
thank you
right um well then i'll now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote please
thank you chair members again if you
could go to the plus sign
in the mod dub app and select attendance
and voting the vote will now be
in progress
thank you chair that is eight votes for
that's unanimous
thanks claire okay uh we're moving on
now to
item 10 which is paper bca 2013
quarter 2 performance presentation i'll
now ask the cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
to provide an introduction
thank you chair thank you very much and
as this uh is just
for reporting obviously we're not taking
a vote on this it is just for reporting
uh so i'm going to ask uh immediately
for um our assistant director for for
customers sarah wilcock to
report thank you thank you
thank you councillor parker and good
afternoon councillors
i'd like to present baybach district
council's quarter two performance
which commences on page 41 of your
papers
this is the second iteration of our new
and refreshed style format
designed to provide a flavour and
overview of how the council has been
performing for the most part from july
through to september
a snapshot in time illustrated through
some performance indicators and
objectives which
link directly back to our corporate plan
presentation is themed based on our six
key prior
priorities within the corporate plan
communities
housing well-being customers environment
and economy
we also include a theme titled health of
the organisation
which reflects work undertaken to
provide the foundations for an effective
and efficient organization
without running through the entirety of
the content of the presentation i would
like to pick out a few key points though
undoubtedly throughout the summer months
there has been a continued focus on our
response to the coronavirus pandemic
with activities highlighted in the
presentation including proactive contact
with
high-risk businesses to ensure
appropriate risk assessment
and working practices were in place
distribution of over 24 million pounds
of grants to our businesses and
continued support provided to our
amazing community groups and
individuals additionally progress was
made against corporate plan objectives
including drafting and approval of our
biodiversity action plan
commencement of our nbq training program
to develop in-house skills for staff to
review and redesign processes from a
customer perspective
recruitment of five apprentices and
commencement of works in shot lead
brantham
and progress at angel court delivering
affordable homes for the district
as mentioned this is only the second
iteration of our new style performance
presentation
and we have in this edition also
included a link to a digital case study
which we hope will be the first of many
being able to share
engaging form in engaging content with
you in a format
is much more accessible we will
obviously continue to refine
the style and taking account of feedback
and further improvements will will
continue in line with further quarters
so thank you for your time to present
this and i'll hang back to chair for
comments and noting
ah right got there in the end thank you
uh sarah that's uh
very uh informative thank you so uh
questions from cabinet members counselor
arthi
do you have any questions no i don't
thank you
councillor busby
if it's not confidential could we have
an update on the progress on the
philips site
[Music]
um not
is there anything uh um councillor
parker or anyone can
can answer on that one um
all i know is that um
arthur can can you provide an update i
will not
necessarily provide an update other than
simply to say obviously we continue to
work closely to see how
how that site can be brought forward the
ownership changed
during the course of the year and our
dialogue is hopefully with those new
owners
and clearly our approach and as accounts
in terms of what we want to see there
hasn't altered uh but yeah outside the
meeting we can provide you with a wider
update if that's helpful
yeah thank you councillors davis
no i'm good thank you councillor holt
i'm fine dave say phillips as in
glamswood phillips
yeah i think i i assume that that's what
he's referring to
um do you want to uh make any comment
well i'm happy to pick up with dave
after the meeting i'm not sure there's
anything
confidential as such but obviously the
site has been sold yeah
i'm more than happy to have a
conversation with dave to
sort of brief him as to where we are
with it but um
the site is sold new owners are looking
to put in a planned application
and and that's where we are generally so
um yeah
okay public knowledge so yeah
thanks councilman marvisi um i drove
past it this morning
and the only thing i have to say is that
the phillips avent
badging has been removed and
i think it's ogb is the new badging
that's gone up
yep okay thanks do you have any other
questions on
on this paper nope
councillor osborne no questions mr
chairman thank you
council parker i'll um uh ask you if you
you've got anything further you want to
comment on on this paper
uh uh no chat um just uh really just to
back up what sarah said obviously our
second iteration and and the
uh all of the stats and information that
backs up the the report is all still
available for cabinet members and indeed
for any member that wants to uh
to see it thank you thanks
right uh any other members present um
any questions
uh from you um councilman craw do you
have any questions
none chair thank you right uh if there
are no further questions on
this then um i'll just say that
the item is noted and thank you sarah
that's um
very helpful thank you moving on then
item 11 paper bca 2014
the ict strategy and i'll now ask the
cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
to introduce this report
council parker super job thank you very
much sharon and members will be aware
that we uh we only recently discussed
this
at council um in in the past few weeks
so
hopefully they'll still be fresh in in
members minds and with that in mind i'll
i'll try and keep my introduction brief
but um
but the first thing to say about the ict
strategy is that it is all about
customers
rather than um or less
about the tech that sits behind it the
it element is is if you like the conduit
for us to be able to deliver first class
customer outcomes
um rit as we know is run in conjunction
with suffolk county council and the
strategy
helps us to unlock the value in in that
existing partnership so
what is the strategy uh well i i can
break it down into three strands and
shortly i'll
i'll invite matt to talk but break it
down into three strands so
the outcome of the strategy is about
customers residents and ensuring that
we're
able to deliver better outcomes for
everybody
uh it's focused on unblocking value in
the partnership with um suffolk county
council and indeed our existing software
suite
and and it's about the building blocks
uh of the strategies that are informed
by
people process and data um just a few
words about how
the strategy has come about because it's
um you know it's a whole new thing for
us new
journey um and so some time ago and in
the previous administration it was
recognized that there needed to be a
change in provision of our
ict sarah wilcock who you just heard
from
our assistant director for customers and
digital led some work to bring
recommendations forward and as a result
of those recommendations we restructured
ict to bring the team who look after our
business applications back into the
council
which enabled them to be closer and to
respond better to the needs of the
council
so with the addition of matt harding our
it corporate manager we've worked on
strengthening that relationship with
suffolk county
to enable us to realize the potential
but moreover to extract the value from
that relationship
um and it's those steps that have
provided the foundations upon uh
which we we build the strategy so um so
that's the introduction
chair um i'm i'm glad to um
uh present the recommendation i'll be uh
i'll be looking for a second uh as well
chair and
i'll ask matt to uh um to
answer any questions that we might have
as well thank you
thank you councillor i'd be happy to uh
to second this
um for you so um
questions from cabinet members council
rather do you have any questions
no thank you chairman councillor busby
no thanks castle davis
no thank you
um
sorry i just lost my screen here uh
counselor hold
no i'm fine john thank you castle
malvisi
none thank you mr chairman councillor
osborne
no questions mr chairman thank you very
much
okay um leos assume you don't have i've
just got one question
actually and that's um uh the the
reference to
the low code tool sets um uh
has a have tool sets been selected yet
or
are we just going with the the sort of
the standard microsoft offering
um and to what extent are those going to
be
um only used by its support staff for
whether
specific users in various um service
areas will be
trained in in the use of of loco tools
so that they can produce their own
apps in in a flexible and
agile manner
thank you i'm happy i'm happy to take
that and
good afternoon cabinet the answer is a
little bit of both so yes we already
have microsoft tools in terms of the low
code stuff that they do on the power
automate platform
and we are starting to use those within
it
whilst we develop the guard rails that
will enable others to use them safely
so that's one thing we also have a
digital champions approach that we hope
to bring forward that will
to all intents and purposes bolster the
i.t capacity by enabling the wider
organization
to undertake their own automations
secondly we are looking at potentially
new tool sets
specifically in the digital
transformation and end-to-end
digitization of process speeds
that may also include additional low
code tools
thank you thanks sarah did you want to
come in on that
no it's fine thank you that uh matt was
able to um
to jump in there i couldn't get my video
and audio
thanks very much thank you um right then
um
council mccraw do you have any questions
nunchur well i'll now move on in
to debate and open this item up for any
further debate if if anyone has any
comments they wish to make
councillorathi do you have any comments
no thank you castle busby
well it probably won't come as any
surprise but i didn't quite understand
what matthew was saying there what are
loco
tools they they are
well they sort of the latest incarnation
of um
what's what's um been available for some
years in terms of uh
graphical development tools um uh
to allow uh people to to build
applications
um uh effectively through um
uh clicking and selecting uh components
pre pre-built um modules rather than
coding from scratch using and requiring
a detailed knowledge of
a particular programming language
they've gotten more sophisticated over
time
thank you matt did you want to add
anything to that
uh just chair that was that was really
well summed up i would suggest that the
simplest way of thinking about it is
lego for developing software yeah
the career in i.t helps
right uh councillor davis yeah um
yeah just just very briefly i think it's
great that you techies love talking
about your ict and your
your stuff and your lego and your tools
and all the rest of it
but lee lee i think um nailed it on the
head right from the beginning
this is about the residence this is
about making it uh easier for
all the people that use our systems and
i think it's great that we're moving
forward at this
and i think it's also excellent that so
many residents have
come on board um yes there's still
obviously a few
who who struggle with technology and
we need to cater for those but more and
more every year
more and more people that percentage
drops and uh
and i think this sort of strategy helps
that
and uh and great well done uh to
everybody on that
thank you castle hole yeah
a couple of things i mean are we
forecasting or planning on new hardware
because
obviously the new way that we've we've
been sort of forced into working since
covid
has i mean i've got a tablet and
really it isn't the most suitable tool
to have
for what we are now doing and the way we
are carrying out our work
yes i have a second screen but
if we are going to continue and and i
think
we probably will continue to hold a lot
of meetings like this
are we sure that we have our hardware as
up to scratch it has
has the power that it needs to to cope
with new systems that we would
that we're introducing and should we and
are we looking at
um a new hardware contract where we are
going to start replacing is that or is
that just a natural progression
how much has covert affected our
planning for hardware
because all i have to say all the
software stuff goes over my head um
and it is good to see people convert
into digital but
as derek alluded to as well we mustn't
forget
that um that those residents that aren't
able to use it and aren't able to cope
with it
um so yeah it's just a hardware point
really
okay thanks um matt do you have uh
an answer for castle hold please
i i do yes the answer is it depends
on the need so in terms of the it and
the hardware
form will follow function if there is a
need
and it is not suitable we will look to
alternative hardware solutions
the the the key thing to state is that
actually
the majority of the um
performance that people may be suffering
from with regards
access to tools heights tool sets like
teams that we're using
tends to be down to local broadband and
obviously as you're aware we are in
partnership with suffolk county council
around a better broadband for suffolk
project as well to try and increase that
across
the district thanks man
councillor melvisi um
i've always worked in a direct customer
interfacing
role so i really do
care about customers
and we have to talk the language that
they talk
and not the language that the techies
talk
and i've got two techies in my family
and that's my concern because we
have a high percentage of the population
is over 65
and they will talk like me
a bit height a pit techie but not holy
techy
um and they will need people to talk
their language
not us expect them to talk our language
and that concerns me thank you
can can i can i answer that um if that's
all right because
i i think that's an entirely valid um
comment councillor malveezy
and um if if i can offer you any sort of
reassurance or comfort uh
in in matt and i don't want to cause any
embarrassment to matt here but in matt
we have somebody actually that is
multilingual uh in so far as he can
uh he can talk techie with uh with
council award
um until the cows come home um but
he i've been immensely impressed by the
way that matt
is able to translate that uh in to
everyday uh language and everyday speak
and and and what is
so crucial about this whole strategy uh
councilman alves he is as and
and thank you um council davis for
mentioning it this
is only about delivery to customers
um and so by definition it has to be in
in plain speak and plain english so
exactly as we say the it is only the
conduit to provide
first-class customer services and and
i'm certainly determined um
uh sarah will know that um since since i
took on the portfolio i i've banged on
remorselessly about um culture
and change and putting the client at the
heart of everything we've done and i
think we've made massive massive strides
towards doing that
as well um and and if i can give some
comfort to counselor halt as well
um you know by by utilizing and
harnessing
and and and teaching people holding
people's hands through this this
progress or process of
engaging with the technology it's
actually going to free us up time
council halt to deal with the most
vulnerable and and the people that that
really
can't uh or for whatever reason haven't
got access to this to this technology so
um the point is we've now got a strategy
we've never had a strategy before
um and so we've we've got a direction
and we've got a vehicle to which
we or in which we can deliver
first-class customer services so
um i hope that that gives members some
some comfort
thank you thanks guys parker
uh councillor osborne
all right thank you mr chairman now i
don't have any questions i just
i would like to make the point that um
i'm
i'm certainly not a techie but i found
it very easy to read
so i'm thankful for that so to me it's a
good piece of work so thank you
thanks um right uh well
i think that's gone through everyone for
debate i don't know councillor uh parker
did you want to
uh sum up before we move to the vote or
um
well well i think i i think i just
inadvertently did
actually change so i'm happy if you want
to move straight to the right
yeah yeah okay that's great well okay
i'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote for this
item
thank you chair once again members if
you could go into your
modern gov app and the vote should
now be showing in blue
how do you scroll down
counselor if you hover your cursor over
the right hand side
and then click at the same click button
at the same time the
the scroll bar should show oh i found it
yeah okay thank you thank you
thank you that's eight votes for chair
that's unanimous
thank you claire right uh moving on to
the next item which is item 12 paper bca
2015
the community infrastructure levy still
expenditure program
december 2020 and i'll now invite the
cabinet member for planning to introduce
the report
council arthi thank you chairman um yes
uh the sell expenditure program contains
an update
on progress on decisions in bedrooms one
to six
so that since we started doing cylinder
warding
from bids also included is a list of
emerging projects for future
consideration
uh which are currently developing that's
appendix a
um paper bc 2015
has four bids recommended to you today
three four cabinet decision and one for
cabinet to note
and i'll briefly run through those ones
we'll do the ones for decision first
um the first one is um 2011
the sudbury and hadley cctv arrangements
um that's from ring fenced and strategic
infrastructure funds
as you'll see from your papers the total
cost of the seal bid there is 183
000 pounds for the capital costs
with revenue contributions coming from
sudbury and hadley town councils
the project supports the district
council's ambitions
of creating safe healthy and vibrant
communities
with a strong and diverse local economy
it also supports the strategic
partnership aims of both
both of the towns and the vision
delivery groups
to attract inward investment enhance
their environmental credentials
and give confidence to those who live
work and visit the towns
the main objective is to prevent and
detect crime
within the town centres of sudbury and
hadley and to make these communities
safer for residents businesses and
visitors
there are large challenges for the
police and community safety partnerships
in both towns
the technical and the technological
advances in cctv
particularly the deployment of mobile
equipment
is a key aspect of how this form of
offending can be deterred
and improve the level of prosecutions
and councillor osborne
touched on this a little bit earlier on
the project is included in the
infrastructure delivery plan
and our infrastructure funding statement
and the project is of a strategic nature
important to both the towns of sudbury
and
hadley in terms of community safety
moving on to b2005 which is in laven the
first of two in lavenham
this one's the re-engineering of
prentiss street car park
including the provision of ev charging
points
the project brings clear community
benefits as it aims to increase
provision
of off-street car parking in the village
through the improvement of the car park
and the creation of five additional
spaces which will take it from
19 to and it also involves the provision
of a new toilet block to replace the
existing provision
in prentice street car park two public
electric vehicle charging points are
also included in the bid
the is promoted as a tourist destination
with its range of shops and hostelries
and serves large hinterland
of surrounding villages and hamlets it
also draws visitors from further afield
and the improved facilities will also
benefit the ages and the less able
of the population the project meets
climate change priorities with the
provision of electric charging points
which will be publicly publicly
available
collaborative spend is achieved in the
bid by working in partnership with
lavender parish council
and the amount of the seal bid is 109
000 109 000 pounds
with lavender paris council contributing
26 261
this is in accordance with the
thresholds of the sill expenditure
framework which you're all familiar with
for community infrastructure and
electric vehicle charging points
it's a district owned car park it's a
baber car park
and subject to funding being achieved
all over necessarily
all other necessary approvals of the
council would be needed
before works can commence on site
the next laven one is b2004
which is at the tent apiece
sheltered accommodation unit and that's
from
local infrastructure fund a total
seal bid of 36 054 pounds
towards the total cost of works of forty
eight thousand and seventy two pounds
ten to peace is um an estate developed
by baber
in the 1960s in large part it comprises
a
sheltered housing scheme for vulnerable
adults it has an elderly population as
has laven as a whole
approximately 33 percent as it current
as
is currently organized this common room
needs to be improved as a space for
vulnerable people to meet and socialize
and the project would provide a safe
homely environment for this to happen
it's an oven ready scheme where
collaborative spend is achieved in
partnership with lavender parish council
the amount of the seal bid is 36 054
pounds
representing 75 per cent of the total
cost of the work
with lavender paris council contributing
12 000 pounds
this is in accordance with the threshold
of the seal expenditure framework
for community infrastructure it's a
district-owned building and subject to
funding being achieved
all other necessarily all other
necessary approvals of the council
would need to be secured before works
can commence
you you will note that i've said
something similar about
both of the lavender schemes they
are both in um or they are both
assets um owned by baby district council
so just to point out to you that
although they are
baber owned and controlled assets
lavender parish council are actually
contributing nearly 40 000 pounds
towards these two schemes
the projects are lavenham
initiatives but the car park the toilets
and centerpiece
are all bdc owned assets
um you may be aware that there has been
discussion in the past about the future
of the management of
the car parks and from a management
point of view
um lavender paris council already manage
the toilets
and operate a um a
box contribution scheme um towards
their maintenance
finally uh move on to the decision for
cabinet to note
um that's b1918 which is
in hinduism and chattisham it's a play
area
improvement scheme um on the playing
fields
it comes from the local infrastructure
fund with the total cost
of 9 920 pounds
83 p that's the total cost of the sell
bid
um total cost of the works four hundred
is 39
pounds and eighty three p the proposal
represents an enhancement
upgrade of the existing facilities the
decision to support the bid for improved
play infrastructure
has occurred under delegated powers for
the reasons set out in the assessment
project spend is small comes under the
ten thousand pound threshold
at nine thousand nine hundred and twenty
pounds and
under the delegated decision limit um
that decision can be made but has to be
noted and reported to you the
spend represents 25 of the total cost of
the works
and is therefore within the sale
expenditure framework threshold
for community infrastructure i'm
proposing the recommendations
as set out in the papers that's a
paragraph 3.1
which is to make decisions as
recommended for lavenam and sudbury
um sorry lavenam and sudbury and hadley
for the cctv and the two towns and to
note the delegated decision taken at
hindelsham
and paragraph 3.2 in the recommendations
is asking you to note and endorse the
silly sil
expenditure program dated december 2020.
thank you chairman thank you councillor
arthur
um well we did hear you but your picture
has gone
well no that's okay um
all we had was an empty council chamber
and and you were no longer there
i can see that now i don't know how
that's happened hang on no
no that's um quite something
okay right thank you very much for that
um
first of all uh
council oh i thought i saw your hand up
councillor osborne was that for any
particular reason
yes it was mr chairman um i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest please
in both the
bid for the cctv bearing in mind i'm a
sudbury town councillor
and also in the centerpiece because i
wasn't involved in the initial
discussions on that one so
that's a non-pecuniary on both those
bids thank you mr chairman okay
thank you right well counselor arthur
has proposed this paper may i have a
second
please
who's up second uh anyone like second
second
okay council davis thank you
okay moving on to questions um
councillor busby do you have any
questions
uh no thanks chad councillor davis
good questions no questions counselor
holt
no questions councilman love ec
no questions at this point thank you
chairman
counselor osborne no questions mr
chairman
counselor parker no questions mr
chairman
okay um questions from other members
present uh councilman mccraw do you have
any questions
none chair then i'll move
on to the debate and open up the item
for
any further debate um council busby do
you have anything you wish to
say in in the debate
well only clive mentioned that the
ownership or management of the lavenam
car park and toilets
potentially might shift towards 11 am
away from baber
i just wonder what this position on that
is and uh
how that would impact on this little bit
um yeah it doesn't impact on this
particular bid
i suppose one of the reasons for
mentioning it is that the ambition at
lavenham for a number of years has been
to actually
um take control of the car parks and
toilets in the
um in the village um they've come to an
arrangement with regard
to maintenance of the toilets which they
took over
orbit using the same contractor
they do a little bit of
work in the car parks um just i suppose
simply because there are times when um
they're not looking as
as good as they should do um but their
ambition is to actually
um take over the the full management
um of the car parks and toilets both
toilets in lavanama within the car parks
um and their ambition is to um to take a
lease
um in order to properly manage those
moving forward
um and i think i mentioned that they did
introduce um
an honesty box for contributions um
which has
helped um in their costs
of maintaining the toilets to a a good
standard
um the links to this bid i suppose are
that both sets of toilets are getting a
bit tired
um and they um
are not particularly compliant with
regard to
the the provisions for um kovid
um in that they have shared space within
them
um rather than having a cubicle with
four facilities
so their um their intention is to imply
uh to replace both sets of toilets um
the bid that we've got here is for
prentice street um which is just at the
back of
the the marketplace in lavenham
and um they have already submitted a bid
for the other car park
and the the reorganization i suppose
you'd call it
um of the toilet facilities um in church
street
so this is um as far as car parks and
toilets are concerned this is sort of
phase one of of the
improvement to toilets and car parks in
laven
okay thanks so much
councillor davis yeah um there's a
couple of points i'd like to make uh
first of all i think seal's brilliant i
absolutely love it it's one of the best
things i think this council
um has adopted or you know obviously it
was a previous administration but i
think it's one of the best things we've
adopted
for two reasons a the developers know
where their money's going
and they can see it actually helps the
communities so
that that's great and i use the the cctv
example in sudbury
and and hadley it really seriously
needed updated
but we have where do we get the money
from well still is has proved to be the
perfect point
and i think um the the second point i'd
like to make is
we need to um to sell this story in
terms of the wholesale
so more people apply more people use the
community infrastructure levy
both from baber and obviously in their
own neighborhood
development and finally i just want to
again say what a fantastic job
um clive and his team have done
christine thurlow i know
in terms of the sill has has worked
wonders and
so yeah so please climb pass on your
mind
and i'm sure the rest of the cabinets
thanks and congratulations for
the amount of work they have to do to
get this is it's incredible
yeah uh i think we'd all agree with that
castle davis
and and certainly uh you're quite right
um
that uh the cctv proposal is
is a clear example of something that has
been desperately needed
and would never have happened if it
wasn't for sale so um it's proving it's
worth
councillor halt yeah i totally agree
with that
uh john i think that the cctv is a great
example of how this
should and can be used and for both
communities in hadley and sudbury
it's going to give them such reassurance
and for businesses as well as
as well as residents i'm sure when we
first debated this and discussed it
mobile cameras were part of
this scheme and i hope that is still the
case
as it has been mentioned previously
today so
yeah overwhelmingly support that it's a
fantastic
thing for both market towns moving on to
lavadam the infrastructure for the two
evs
um i would like some clarification if
the infrastructure that's going to be
put in would actually support more than
two in the future
because obviously with the growing um
electric car market the chances are
we're going to need more than two
in the short or not too distant future
and
the other point that's been raised is
the sort of ownership um
i'll be very cautious of handing over
any of our assets at the moment
um and i hope this isn't a condition of
this application
because if it was i certainly wouldn't
support it thank you
thanks council um uh council arthur i
don't know if you can just confirm that
but it's my understanding that there are
there are no conditions
um yet um attached to this seal bid
because uh although lavender has
has um signaled an interest that there's
been no further progress on
on on that in terms of transferring the
assets
um no it's it's kind of ongoing i mean i
think the original
intention was that um that they might
seek
um a transfer of the freehold
um that um now seems to
have been replaced by um a
likely opportunity for them to have a
lease um
i think the the thing about lavenam is
that it's you know it's not
quite like ordinary shopper type car
parks um
and um the level of use of the toilets
is quite um high during the summer
months
and actually having um somebody uh
close by to help keep the maintenance of
those um up to a good standard
is is quite useful so um the fact that
they've managed
the toilets has been a real success um
regarding the car parks they are of
course contributing quite a lot of money
to this project
um the ambition is that they will have
um electric vehicle charging points in
all three of labrum's car parks
there are the two existing car parks and
the proposed one at the gas holder site
at the bottom of water street
and that will also have electric vehicle
charging points
yes the cabling will be in michael
but i think that if there was to be a
significant increase in the number of
charging points it would actually
require a new supply
which has got its own costs associated
thank you thanks councilman
easy um thank you
a lot i'm very supportive of the cctv
for sudbury and hadley and for the
cameras to be mobile i'll
i have nothing else to say thank you
councillor osborne thank you mr chairman
um are we on questions or are we in
debate
i don't have any questions debate sorry
sorry
we're good questions sorry questions
okay i'll come back then when
we go into debate thank you okay
councillor parker
um i don't know if it's a question or
not but i mean first of all i'd just
like to
um echo uh councillor doses thoughts uh
around seal itself i i mean i've been
lucky enough to work
um on the seal working group since
inception um back in the previous
administration and i've often
said that it was the single best piece
of uh of work that i've been involved
with
um whilst whilst being a baba district
council and and the improvements and the
benefits to our communities
are absolutely phenomenal um and and but
but in terms of a question
um i suppose i'm just teasing something
out of the report really because i
noticed for
for example in the suburban hadley um
bid it says it represents
towards the bottom it says unless on
page 98 it represents an acceptable
exception
to the community infrastructure
threshold now you know as a member of
the working team i'm fortunate enough
that i i understand what that means but
um but i'm not sure if other members do
or indeed whether members of the public
that might be following it um
uh follow that as well but um i wonder
if
um counselor arthur whether you can
explain that just you know briefly or
not
for people who might not understand that
yeah perhaps i should have highlighted
that i thought that
my presentation was probably plenty long
enough
um but yeah we we introduced changes
um to the the thresholds
for bids um in one of our framework
reviews
um which said that um bids would only um
be for up to 75 or 75 000 pounds
we made exceptions in the framework for
um for green infrastructure
which is why the electric vehicle
charging point
element of the lavender application
is 100 funded um but the rest
um is not so what this means is that
we're
we're asking and perhaps i should have
highlighted this really
because it's asking you to approve an
exception
in this case um to allow for more than
75 percent
of the funding of the total project to
come from cell funds
does that explain it
i think it makes it absolutely yeah yeah
it makes amply clear chairman thank you
thank you right okay uh questions from
other members um
carson mccraw do you have any questions
no questions i do have a comment but i
can make it at any time you wish
uh you can make it now
thank you chair it's really just to say
that the the sill expenditure framework
on which this is based is subject and
has been subject
to a constant rolling review by overview
and scrutiny
since its very inception in fact um and
at every single stage we've
we we don't always approach it's not a
matter of routine it's something that
scrutiny goes through
from a differing viewpoint because the
expenditure framework has
altered and changed uh according to
circumstance and according to need
so it's really just to obviously i would
uh uh uh say that these are all valid in
every possible way but that's your
decision uh but the actual framework and
on which this is based
uh is something that is subject to
constant re-examination i mean
virtually every six months it seems i've
been living with sill for the last four
years i'm
five years whatever like many members so
that was all it was just to make that
point
thank you right i'll now open
this item up for debate uh councillor
busby do you have anything you wish to
say
uh no thanks council davis anything else
no i've said enough thank you okay
councillor holt
no thank you councilman rbc no thank you
councillor
[Music]
yeah thank you mr chairman yeah with
regards to the sovereign hadley cctv
um this certainly supports the council's
ambitions
to create safe and healthy and vibrant
communities and it's well known that if
you've got a safe town
it will encourage investment into the
town so i am very very much up for this
regarding the mobile cameras i think
it's
key to the success of this um project
i don't believe that mobile cameras are
been allowed for in the actual costume
within this bid
however if that is the case then as i've
already asked
um to have some money ring fenced in the
hra budget
to accommodate the provision of mobile
cameras throughout the area
for particular anti-social hot spots
in regards to um tend to peace
i'm really pleased to see this coming
forward i was in discussions in my role
as cabinet member for housing
i was contacted by the parish council
and i was involved in discussions on
this
and i'm really really pleased to see
this coming forward you know it will be
a real facility for those affected by
dementia and also
other vulnerable people and i have to
say a big thank you
to all the people mainly in lebanon
they've been involved in this coming
forward
lavender and parish council very much
lead by example
and you know for example one of their
things is the community land trust
they're already providing
homes in lavenham so i very much support
this as well it's it's a great project
and i'm looking forward to seeing it
coming to conclusion
thank you mr chairman thanks um council
holt you just put your hand up did you
have anything you wanted to
say on that well it's the mobile cameras
i'm
pretty sure that when we had discussions
at briefings etc that mobile cameras
were going to be part of this
and it would be nice to have some
clarification as to whether this bit
is going to include them it was always
the case
from my point of view that certainly one
and hadley one and sudbury were
going to be part of of any cctv
upgrade so i'd like some clarification
on that
casserole do you have any uh comment on
that
um no i can't give you an answer on that
i do know
that the um the system which um we're
being asked to fund
will accommodate mobile cameras um
whether those
actual cameras are included in this bid
um i can't answer that i have a feeling
that
maybe um mobile cameras are not
infrastructure because they're mobile by
their nature
so the system will definitely
accommodate mobile units
um but whether they're included in this
bid i suspect
not but i can i can get that um
clarified for councillor holt
thank you thanks right finally castle
parker do you have anything else you
wish to say
no thank you chairman okay then well
thanks everyone i'll now ask the
governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors
once again if you could go to the mod
gov app you'd vote
should now show as blue so you can
start your votes
thank you councillors chair that's eight
votes for which is again unanimous
thank you man uh claire sorry um right
moving on to item 13 paper bca 2016
this is the abbycroft financial support
2020 to 2021
now this report is in two parts and part
one is the public part of the report and
part two
is confidential and that covers the
appendices
so i'll now invite the cabinet member
for communities to introduce the report
council davis
thank you very much and as we all know
this has been a truly awful year
but we can look forward to 2021 with
much of
optimism uh and so it is with abby croft
leisure with our
baby support despite all the setbacks
and challenges abbycroft have remained
steadfast throughout
taking some extremely difficult
decisions in terms of staffing and
operational matters
and it is a testament to its robust
responsible
and responsive management that we are in
a position today to be considering the
paper
and its recommendations quite simply
without the hard work close
communications and open book approach
we would be facing a quite dreadful
scenario where our residents will be
facing a future without the leisure
provisions they deserve
desire and need we would have gyms
but not as we know it as our pay tribute
to warren smythe and tracy loins at abby
croft
and all their team and catherine melissa
and cassandra here at baber
members should remember the dire straits
we were in during the two lockdowns
and it is only superb financial
management that has kept the
vitally important leisure center
provisions at hadley and kingfishers
sudbury
afloat no no one should doubt the
importance of gyms
swimming pools fitness classes and other
offshoots these
facilities bring to the physical and
mental health well-being
of our residents from six months old to
90 plus
yes we can swim in the rivers or the sea
if we're lucky enough to be close enough
or run and walk in the parks and open
spaces but our leisure centers offer far
more in terms of motivation variety
and safety in staying fit and healthy in
mind and body
this brings me into abby croft's
importance to baber as a not
not for profit management company with a
skill set we would find hugely difficult
to replicate
even with our outstanding staff we have
at baber
this means the loan in the first
instance followed by the grant is hugely
important to allow abbycroft to continue
to service at baber
both as a council and for our residents
through to next march when hopefully
vaccinations will have taken effect and
the leisure centers will be up and
operating as near to normal as possible
the details within the paper provide the
specifics
although myself and cassandra will be
happy to take questions
meanwhile i commend the recommendation
3.1 to 3.3
to the cabinet without hesitation
thank you chair thank you counselor
did you really mean that star trek
reference jim's but not as we know it
i'm glad someone picked up on it
okay thank you may i have a second to
please
i'm happy to second that uh mr chairman
thank you councillor general's one
thanks catherine thank you right uh
questions from cabinet members counselor
arthi do you have any questions
um thank you chairman i don't have a
question but i i will contribute when
you
open the debate thank you okay yeah
castle busby
no thanks uh council hull
uh just one thing i wouldn't recommend
swimming in rivers
ah i used to when i was a lad
yeah we do in shortly yeah your rivers
are cleaning shortly then but i wouldn't
recommend
it down at the store at catawade yeah
um councilor malvisi
um i'd like an answer for why
the grant is greater than the loan
i'll pass that on to cassandra i think i
know the answer
but i want to be very clear
sure thank you very much councillor
davies and good afternoon cabinet
so to answer that question councillor
malfoy the loan
is based on the uh assets that the
um that abby croft own and so the loan
has to be secured against those assets
and therefore can't uh total more than
what their assets are worth
thank you sales thanks guys yeah
councillor osborne
no questions mr chairman thank you
councillor parker uh no questions mr
chairman i'll i'll join in the debate i
will just say that it's the stower not
the store but
well i can
i think it depends on where in the
district you live yeah
okay um questions from any other members
council macro
do you have any none sure
right we'll move into debate then
councillor arthi
yeah thank you chairman um i
i've been on the couch for quite a long
time now i joined just after we
we built kingfisher oh god
leisure center which was just over 30
years ago
these facilities are are our facilities
they're our swimming pools
and leisure facilities and in hadley
we've just built a completely new
swimming pool
um this year kovid 19 has presented us
with huge challenges um
but we we cannot abandon our leisure
centers
and just walk away from them and
as a result we cannot leave abbycroft
high and dry
either as councillor
davis has said things will return to
something closer to normal
and we have to go through this period
and we have to
help abbycroft go through this period
so that we can return to a position
where we have properly managed um
properly funded
and and good usable
accessible facilities in in hadley and
sudbury
so i i support um
the the help that we're
giving to abbycroft so that we can
return to a position
where our facilities are hopefully back
to normal
thank you thank you councillor busby
no thanks
counselor davis well i presume you said
everything you wanted to say in your
uh introduction do you have anything
else you wish to add not at the moment
but
if people yeah that's not the moment
castle holt yeah i've always had
concerns about the amount of money we
seem to be giving um abbycroft
and with what we've given them already
plus another 270 000
and another 150 loan in a time when we
are trying
or public money's so scarce and we're
having trouble with the budget
i do have issues with how much money
we're pumping and i take
clive's comments 100 in in that they are
essential services
but we are giving money to a
to an outside body um with no real
guarantees
of of those centers remaining open
and operating and the long-term future
i think we do have to look at how we
manage
our leisure centers so that we are in
far
more control and a better control of the
financial aspects
um going forward so yes i
i i struggle with the amount of money
that we are looking to
put into that we would say it won't come
back to us at grants with the exception
of the 150
000 um and when it a lot of people are
struggling
a lot of businesses are struggling and
um we face what we face at the moment
is a difficult decision i think far more
than what other members seem to think
thank you thanks councilman ovc
thank you chair um i think
councillor holt has expressed my
concerns
um a lot of people
are going to come out of covert having
lost their jobs
at best maybe lost their homes
they won't be able to afford gym or
leisure center membership
so i would be
i'd be looking at a reduction in income
even though a lot of people will be
suffering from all sorts of illnesses
and side effects of covert
we're going to a leisure center and
uh exercising will be highly beneficial
to them
but i still think that their revenue
stream
will be much reduced moving forward
and that's going to take several years
for them to claw back just to get back
onto an even keel
of pre-covered sales
so like counselor holt i'm
it concerns me deeply because the 270
grant
will just disappear down the tube
if they don't survive so they have got
to make it work
there's no ifs and buts they have got to
make it work
because as councillor halt pointed out
we're
we've been trying to balance the budget
we've been trying to find money from
absolutely everywhere
and here we are giving a grant
that some people may consider the
equivalent of what we were looking for
thank you councillor councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman i actually
also share councillor halt's
concern as will some members of the the
public i know
but however it you know it's about
getting the balance
right and the the pros proposal before
us today
is the right balance we all know how key
having um
facilities to enable us to keep healthy
both physically and mentally
is really really key and we're going to
need as we come out of this dreadful
situation
we're going to need even more you know i
know i've missed the leisure center
and um many other people are missing it
as well and the sooner we can get back
to using it
the better so um the balance before us
today
it's the right one and you know i
referred to earlier about councillors
having to make some hard decisions this
obviously is a hard decision
but i'm confident that the decision
we're making at this point of time
is the right decision thank you mr
chairman
thank you council parker
thank you um chair i mean it really is a
tough decision there's no question about
it in in in the straightened times but
but i'm i'm just naturally well saying
naturally i'm just more optimistic
about the future for the leisure center
um it's a not-for-profit business
so i i do think that it's a little
i think it's a little bit unfair to say
that if if we
had direct control of the situation that
we would be able to have made a better
job
um than than than the current management
have
at abbycroft i mean it's just a unique
set of circumstances that have arrived
here but as a not-for-profit business
what it needs is customers passing
through and
if we don't have covid we will have
customers passing through the tools will
ring and everything will balance
so i'm i'm i'm a lot more optimistic
i i think naturally you know with with
everything that's going on this week
with the vaccines that are coming etc we
are
certainly in for still a very bumpy 12
months so
but here's a question uh mr chairman i
mean off the grant on the loan that
that's being proposed here
uh if if if you know if those leisure
centers stay closed
for you know for the next however many
months how long will this
will this amount of money last
so can i answer that yeah yes counselor
yeah um
as it says in the paper we're looking um
to for the money to be used up until
march which would be the year end um it
has to be said that the furlough scheme
has helped abbycroft
no end because that's that's relieved a
lot of the pressure
and as you've mentioned councillor
parker this is
a not-for-profit organization it's not
an outside body
that's making money out of baby it's
quite the opposite
you know if if we didn't use abbycroft
we would have to manage this ourselves
and we wouldn't be able to give
ourselves a grant for example we would
have to find the funding from other
other
other areas um it's hugely important
the and uh and just to reassure people
when the gyms are open they're very well
used both in sudbury and hadley
and we don't have the specific figures
yet for coming out of lockdown they'll
they'll come
seven days after the end of this year
but they are very well used and if if we
didn't use abbycroft we would have to
manage this ourselves and
and obviously all the resources that
that would take
so in terms of the actual loan and the
the grant i think it's actually it's a
good use of the money
unless what we're saying is we're either
going to mothball
both the swimming pools and the gyms of
which we've invested a huge amount of
money
um or we're just going to just turn our
backs on it all together
and not give our residents the the
leisure
facilities they need for both the
physical and mental health well-being as
i said in my introduction um we can't
turn our back on it
yes we have to make difficult decisions
but i thought you know i think this is
an easy decision in many ways
um i think we're very fortunate to have
abby croft running them for us because
they are very prudent
and they work extremely closely with our
our teams
and also of course they they work in
other with other local councils as well
west suffolk for
being a prime example and sin
edmondsbury
so yeah i can understand
certain concerns but for me you know
this keeping the leisure centers afloat
literally
right up until march that and that's
what this money is aimed for
and then they can get back on an even
kill and we can reassess it
you know once things return to some sort
of normality
these are our facilities they're babies
abu croft run it for us and they run it
they run it for us very very well thank
you chad
thank you thank you council davis castle
hold did you
uh you've got your hand raised yeah i'll
say something in response yeah
uh yes they are an outside body um and
they are a non-for-profit organization
but we are
pumping a lot of money into that
non-profit organization just as you say
to keep our leisure centres
open and operating so it is a difficult
decision
based on that alone that we are given
money outside of our organization
with no real guarantees if we have
um and i don't want to look back and say
if we if this and if that but derek
mentioned it
if we hadn't taken control ourselves we
would have got government funding for it
during this crisis so you know that's
retrospect you can't look back you can't
change that but
uh there would have been support
available to us if we had to run it
ourselves
um it is a bit of a gamble because as as
councillor mulvacey said that
there's no guarantee with this at all
and i take other members
comments on board that this is such an
essential part of
our residents well-being and we we do
own them and they are ours but
it's just the amount of money we're
talking about
handing it over to an outside body it
makes it a very difficult decision
that that's that's what i want to say
thank you
counselor arthi yeah i just wanted to
support what councillor davis
said um you know notwithstanding
um what councillor holt said about um
some
other funding um that may have been
available to us from the government um
if we were running this facility
um it's been a very very difficult year
and if we didn't have abbycroft managing
these facilities
all of abbycroft's losses in the first
instance would be our losses
so um you can balance
the what if but as council halt said
we're not in
you can't go back we're not in a what if
situation
so i think that given what's happened
this year
if if we don't
step in and help i think the position is
worse than
any of the other what-if scenarios
because we would end up with facilities
in the case of hadley and the pool is
brand new
um we would have facilities that we
couldn't
easily and quickly step in and manage um
we would have abby croft um who
we would um effectively be allowing
to to to fail um
and we would then have a lot of work to
do
um to to try and put something in place
to get the leisure centres reopened and
provide for their ongoing management so
i think that um without abbycroft
we would have been in a worse position
this year and i think
moving forward we will be in a much
worse position if we don't
keep them afloat and keep them on board
thank you councillor davis
yeah just to add um abby croft
will be in the mix along with every
other leisure center in the country or
leisure center providers
uh for for government money which is uh
still to be finalized
so uh the the government option is still
there but
because we don't know what's going on
with that or when that will come
we can't add that in at the moment and
and i'm sure cassandra or someone else
can correct me if i'm wrong than that
yeah um that there is a hundred million
pounds ring fence pot
for uh third-party um outsourced leisure
providers to bid into
they have to submit bids um and i know
abby croft are
working on a bid and i know we're
helping them and west suffolk's helping
them
um but uh there is uncertainty there
uncertainty over success
and in this successful uncertainty over
how much um
will eventually come to to avicroft so
um
there's a lot of unknown around that at
the moment so um
we're having to make decisions here uh
based on an
assumption that that that's that's not
part of the the mix that's not part of
our considerations but um if it is then
then it would be
very helpful and would probably um
uh reduce the the need for the um
that the full 270 000 pound grant but um
that's that's not something that i think
we can consider here at this stage
counselor busby yeah i think you kind of
mentioned the point that um
abby croft let manage leisure centers in
other
districts uh and we really need to
coordinate the approach on that i think
if we just
bailed out that would put a lot of
pressure on the other districts as well
yeah from my point of view um abby croft
have have proven
up until covert to be a sound provider
of leisure services that they they
manage the centers very well
um they manage their finances very well
that they're hit as indeed
um many other most other businesses have
been hit by
an unprecedented event this year um
and that they're they're responding uh
in in a professional and uh and sensible
way
they're looking at um how they can uh
restructure their finances to see them
through this and and
part of that is assistance from
ourselves and and from west suffolk and
um
i i think that they've certainly
satisfied us that um
they've got a sound um plan in place
for for seeing through the rest of of
this uh
crisis and and uh hopefully to full
reopening and full resumption of
services
um the thing we have to to remember
is that um leisure provision
is although not a
statutory service it is an essential
service so many people rely on it
and it's key to our whole the whole of
our um well-being strategy
going forward um the the numbers of
people that use both sudbury and hadley
um are very significant and so the
impact
on a huge percentage of our our
community would
would be massive uh should should these
these leisure centers not open
and when looking at all the alternatives
to to providing them with this
loan and grant combination all of the
alternatives
would be far more financially
um difficult for us to sustain that it
is the the most
cost-effective option um to do this to
support abbycroft and to keep them going
and to have faith and and confidence in
in their ability to
to recover and to provide a good leisure
service going forward
counselor arthi
i'm so sorry that's a legacy hand okay
then
right well um if there are no further
comments uh questions um i don't
think does anyone wish to move into the
second uh into the
private session to to look at um the um
the the details of the the financial
aspect in
in the uh confidential paper if not
i'd be happy to um conduct the vote but
does does anyone want to
to look at or to discuss or question the
the confidential papers in any way at
this stage
nope in which case i'll ask the
government to stop
so to conduct the electronic vote please
thank you so much so just one thing kind
of clarification
are we just voting on bc 2016
um just the paper we've seen or are we
voting on the
the confidential one as well are we
taking them both together are they one
of them
yes yeah and we'd only move into the
confidential session should we wish to
um
uh to um uh
talk about that confidential paper
unless
chair can i just confirm that all of the
recommendations were in the
public paper so the confidential part of
the
report was just the appendices there's
no recommendations contained in there
yeah okay thank you
okay members so the vote is has now
started
so if you go to your mod gov app you'll
be able to vote
thank you chair that's seven votes four
and one against so that is carried
great thanks claire right everyone well
thank you very much for that
uh that draws today's cabinet meeting to
a close
and the next meeting will be thursday
the
7th of january at 5 30 p.m
so um thank you everyone um
and uh see you at the next cabinet
well see you before but formally at the
next cabinet meeting next year
and it's going to be a better year next
year
you